many americans lined up early to cast
their ballots
and tens of millions of americans are
expected to vote today
that is on top of record early voting
numbers that have already come
in our most recent cbs news battleground
tracker poll
has former vice president joe biden in
the lead but all that could change
cbs news elections and surveys director
anthony salvanto shows us
what each candidate will need to win the
white house
here's a viewer's guide to watching
election night the first thing to know
is that millions of ballots have already
been cast a record number
and it might be most of the ballots that
will be cast
we also know politically that joe biden
has a lead in those early ballots
the question is can that lead stand up
to what could be
a republican turnout surge on election
day let's take a look at the map and
which states to watch
a possible path for joe biden
could run up through the upper midwest
winning states the president won
in 2016 taking back places like
wisconsin
michigan pennsylvania where joe biden
came in
with polling leads for the president his
path
probably starts going back through the
sun belt
places like arizona which has become a
toss up florida
always a close race georgia north
carolina and then back
up through the upper midwest for him
ohio
iowa and trying to flip back into his
column again
pennsylvania which could put him back
over
into the top one of the big things to
watch tonight as the results
come in is remember this is a 50-state
race
it is the electoral college that decides
the presidency
and it should be an exciting night an
important reminder thank you anthony
chief washington correspondent major
garrett joins us now major good morning
good morning
from what you've heard from both
campaigns
going into this election day finally
we're here how confident
are they at this stage i think both
campaigns and
candidates kind of know where things are
they have a better sense than the voters
do
and i think it's very important to go
back to what was said last night by the
two candidates joe biden for the first
time
said i think we're going to win and he
started talking about america in a
post-trump era
joe biden is nothing if not cautious him
saying that out loud is a reflection
of the internal data that they're going
through what did donald trump say
yesterday
could this guy win yeah could joe biden
win those are reflections of what
they're
already absorbing about what they've
seen at their state level data and
national data i think that's very
important on the confidence scale
joe biden is a completely different
place than he was just two days ago
go ahead go ahead i think we should
manage viewers expectations
going into this evening a lot of tension
in the air how is the night likely to
look
for the president given when polls are
closing and those first results are
going to be coming in
so there's this phrase people may have
heard that i don't really like
red mirage because it sounds pejorative
it sounds like it's a phony thing it's
not a phony thing
votes are counted and they're real
they're not a mirage but
they're not the entire picture so on day
of
turnout if the trump turnout is very
very high those votes will be counted
first
doesn't mean they're worth more or less
they're just counted first but they will
look
better for the president then you add
absentee early in
voting and then in-person voting then
the tabulation begins to look a little
bit different it's not a mirage
it's just a combination of things so in
some states
the president could jump out to what
looks like an early lead if that lead
dissipates it doesn't mean anything's
going on it just means
all votes are being tabulated right and
the trump campaign rhetoric
in court and in person is all votes
counted
all votes legally counted well let's
count all the votes but the early
impression may be misleading
it may indicate something that over time
doesn't hold up
and that's why you have to be patient
because just because it's taking a long
time doesn't mean that there's something
wrong precisely but i want to compare
2016 major because you were there
what are the similarities and
differences you see between these two
campaigns well 2016 i was on the road
for 16 months and i was on airplanes and
cars this campaign i've covered from my
couch oh yeah
big difference yes uh the other would be
comfortable the other big difference
and this is really important 2016 was a
change election
hillary clinton was trying to extend for
four more years in existing political
orientation the obama administration
effectively it's a very hard thing to do
in american politics
on my podcast the debrief robbie mook
the campaign manager for hillary clinton
acknowledged that they didn't understand
how difficult that was
this is not a change election this is a
referendum election on the president's
handling of everything
and because it's a referendum he is the
central focus of this election
back then it was change and do you want
to take a chance on a newcomer yeah a
lot of americans just decided quickly
are you expecting the president may try
to declare victory early if the early
votes suggest he's ahead
and are you expecting legal challenges
from him the republicans have given
every indication that that's on the
president's mind
i will always give the president and any
political figure the room to not do what
their
advisors say they're going to do if this
is
decisive for biden early on i don't
expect the president to do that but if
it's close
be ready and we can say we're ready
we are ready we can definitely say we're
going to be a great night i think so
it's going to be a long night
really really looking forward to that
coming up next